دقيقه صمت في التندون ستريت في الذكرى
الاولى للحرب الاوكرانيه
واخرى في مجلس الامن الدولي
حلفاؤكيف حول العالم عبروا عن تضامنهم مع
الشعب الاوكراني بدءا بالرئيس الفرنسي
ايمنوي
الاوكرانيون والاوكرانيات فرنسا تقف
بجانبهم من اجل التضامن والنصر والسلام
اما جاره الالماني اولى فاختار ان يوجه
رساله عبر الفيديو وحث فيها رئيس روسي على
وقف الحرب كلما ادرك الرئيس الروسي سريعا
انه لن يحقق اهدافه الامبرياليه ازدادت
الفرص لانتهاء الحرب قريبا بوتين يمسك كل
الاوراق بيده بامكانه وضع حد لهذه الحرب
مع مرور عام على بدء الحرب يزور رئيس
الوزراء البولندي كييف للقاء فولودي
مرزيلنسكي فرصه ايضا للاعلان عن تسليم
الدفعه الاولى من دبابات الايوبارد
المانيه الصنع الى اوكرانيا
ارسلنا اربع دبابات الى كييف ونحن مستعدون
لارسال المزيد بسرعه
غربيه اخرى تعهدت امداد كييف باسلحه ثقيله
مثل السويد قد قررنا ارسال عشر دبابات من
طراز اثنان الى اوكرانيا
يحاول قاده الدول الغربيه دعم كييف عسكريا
من جهه والضغط على موسكو من جهه اخرى من
خلال الاعلان عن رزمه جديده من العقوبات
الامريكيه على روسيا بعد عام تماما على
بدء غزوها اوكرانيا